Anita nagpur Hong Kong réalisateur chinois
kana tante Angela la présidence lon capa
Amérique là-bas l'équipe vocale est
un cracker miss crackers son militant
dans Exodus entre les conteneurs en
personne je vois occuper mon cockamamie a
accepté la confiance anova sur toxique el
camino de voz anarchie pallidus peu spectaculaire
toucher la communauté contre
casado que tenham dans chaque livre hua ji
ji reçoit bonjour des frais conscients et traîne
et les gens écouteront le
problème numéro un qui est discuté pour les
personnes queer à New York est la sécurité en ce
moment où les gens sont attaqués assez
régulièrement nous don  Je ne me sens pas en sécurité, il semble
difficile de croire
que la sécurité est un tel problème dans une ville
comme New York quand vous voyez des
policiers partout, ouais, ce que les gens
ne comprennent pas, personne qui ne fait pas partie
de la communauté queer ne
comprend pas que les homosexuels ne le sont pas.  en sécurité
n'importe où il n'y a aucun endroit au monde
où nous sommes en sécurité et New York est l'un
des endroits les plus sûrs pour nous et
nous sommes toujours  Je ne suis pas en sécurité Je ne pense pas
trop à qui va gagner non Je pense
plus à m'assurer que tout le monde dans
la communauté queer est engagé et que
tout le monde participe aux votes et
que tout le monde se prononce et
parle des problèmes  dont il faut
parler, je pense qu'il
y aura une grande différence pour nous de
toute façon si Trump ou Clinton gagne non,
nous serons toujours en Amérique et l'
Amérique est pleine de 300 millions d'Américains,
c'est trop vous savez comment  être
il y a beaucoup d'Américains c'est beaucoup
de gens, je suis sûr que vous n'aimez même pas
quand il y a un Américain dans l'une de
vos chambres maintenant nous avons 300 millions d'
Américains où est donc peu importe
qui gagne au  En fin de compte, c'est
toujours un pays plein d'Américains et la
plupart des Américains sont pleins de haine envers
les personnes homosexuelles, donc je ne me concentre pas sur qui
va gagner les élections ou essayer de
pousser une personne à gagner, je veux
m'assurer que je  Je soutiens clairement les gens
qui votent que je ne suis pas  parler de cela dans mes
émissions, les Américains ne se présentent pas pour qu'elle
vote et donc les Américains queer ne se présentent pas non
plus pour voter, donc je pense
que pousser les gens queer à voter euh pourrait
faire une grande différence si nous nous présentons et
personne d'autre ne salue quelqu'un nous pourrions
enfin faire une différence pour être entendu